من اهم المبررات التي ساقتها موسكو لشن
حربها على اوكرانيا زحف شرقا في اتجاه
الحدود الروسيه لكن هذه الحرب دفعت فنلندا
والسويد لطلب عضويه الحلف فماذا تعني هذه
العضويه تعني اقتراب الحلف اكثر فعمليا
سيضيف النيتو
متر من الحدود مع روسيا وستمكنه الحدود
الفنلنديه من اطول حدود بريه معها وهذا ما
سيعزز وجود النيتو في منطقه بالغه
الحساسيه وهي بحر البلطيق في عام 2004
انضمت دول البلطيقه الثلاث ليتوانيا
واستونيا للحلف لكن صغر حجمها والبعد عن
مركز الثقل في الحلف جعلت تلك الدول تعيش
خوفا دائما من جارها الروسي الان بانضمام
فنلندا وفي انتظار انضمام السويد سيتعزز
امن هذه الدول الصغيره منطقه اخرى لا تخفى
اهميه الاستراتيجيه هي القطب الشمالي
الوضع الجغرافي لفندا والسويد سيمنح الحلف
نفودا اوسع في المنطقه الشاسعه بعد اكمال
انضمامهما ما يشكل تهديدا للمصالح
الاستراتيجيه لروسيا التي استثمرت كثيرا
هناك بعد ان اظهرت الدراسات غنى المنطقه
بالثروات الطبيعيه تعد مملكه السويد من
الدول القليله في شمال اوروبا التي تعاملت
بالنديه مع روسيا القيصريه طوال قرون
وخاضت معها حروب لبسط النفود هناك ولذلك
فعندما يكتمل انضمامها الى الحلف ستجد
روسيا نفسها امام تحدي لا يستهان به وما
يزيد من حجم هذا التحدي ان السويد تعد قوه
عسكريه كبيره وتملك صناعه حربيه من بين
الافضل في العالم فهي تصنع غواصات وصواريخ
وطائرات متطوره وتملك سلاحا جويا يعد من
الافضل في اوروبا والعالم كما تملك قوه
بحريه لا يستهان بها اما الجيش السويدي
فهو جيش محترف يعتمد على التقنيات الحديثه
ويملك عتادا متطورا وانضمامه الى الحلف
سيقويه ويزيده فعاليه في الشمال الاوروبي
ورغم ان قوه فنلندا العسكريه اقل من
السويد فان وضعها الجغرافي ربما يجعل
انضمامها اكثر ازعاجا لرو سيا فرسيا التي
سعت لابعاد النيتو تجده الان يجاورها على
امتداد مئات الكيلومترات وقبل الانضمام
بسنوات قامت فنلندا بعمليه لتحديث لجيشها
وخصصت ميزانيه كبيره للدفاع
[موسيقى]